and finally new rule hooray for the
cracks that have finally emerged in the
blue wall of silence
yes eternal optimist that I am I'm gonna
look on the bright side of fires and
looting in the breakdown of all order in
the United States and hail the police
chiefs from across the country who knelt
and marched with the protesters in
miami-dade County in New York City and
Santa Cruz California and Flint Michigan
and lots of places houston police chief
art acevedo even said he was outraged at
Americans who don't see a problem this
is new wasn't that long ago police never
even admitted they did anything wrong
police sergeant Howard banks of Omaha
said it's all of us versus bad people
and bad cops and we want to get them out
of the line of duty and police work well
there I'm gonna have to stop it because
honestly it's not quite that simple I
mean forever we've been talking about
bad cops
you know bad apples and then the vast
majority of cops good cops but the real
new rule is you can't anymore get away
with this is a bad cop and any cops who
aren't actually committing the crime are
good the ones who watch and do crowd
control for atrocities they're not good
either that has to be the new standard
and it goes for all out of line behavior
if your partner is doing something
horrendous you can't just watch and do
nothing like the husband in a cup video
there's a meme that says nobody hates
bad cops worse than good cops okay if
you hate them so much turn them in
because let's be real if there wasn't
video of that murder how do you think
those other cops would have described
that encounter it would be we found mr.
Floyd unresponsive so we administered
CPR blah blah blah lie lie lie if you
see something say something has to apply
to police
- you can't get away with crimes on
account of being the people who were
supposed to stop crimes and speaking of
stopping crimes we were a little slow to
get to that in LA this week I mean
sometimes I feel like we're getting the
worst of both worlds the abusive part of
policing but without the Law & Order
part I've said many times in discussing
the police civilization is a mile wide
and an inch deep so when people say cops
are all that stands between civilization
and chaos absolutely I agree cops are
the badasses who deal with the dregs in
an ugly business but if cops want us to
give them a little extra room to be
tough because they've got a bad
dangerous job then they got to do the
bad dangerous job
which they have also done plenty of this
week to be fair this is this is tough
stuff now but it was frustrating
watching it on TV last Sunday car 54
where were you it looked like Black
Friday but without cash registers I did
see a guy in Santa Monica turning away
looters but it wasn't a cop just a guy
invoking a citizen's doorman and this
young woman why even under these very
difficult circumstances for the police
is she having to do this in a country
that is teeming with police forces one
thing America does not lack for is
police forces local cops state county
highway Sheriff's Department federal
marshals ATF DEA FBI TSA oh we got cops
but this lady had to step up I try to
understand as much as I can without
being a cop that it's not like the jobs
most people have and it's not when a
voice on the radio says men with machete
on 15th and main you have to go to 15th
in May
and I'm guessing cops rarely get called
out to a rednecks front porch because
the guy wants to tell you how well the
marriage is going it's a dangerous job
yeah but I think we lose our battle with
police misconduct when before a bad cop
hits the streets because there's not
enough vetting about who becomes a cop
in the first place
I swear to god I think the root of the
problem with bad cops isn't always
racism it's high school how much of high
school did you spend inside a locker
should be question number one on the
psych evaluation I've known quite a few
cops in my day and others I've met for
briefer encounters on the side of the
road and they are mostly not that guy
but that guy is who we have to weed out
instead of LAPD making the psych eval
the last step in joining the force make
it the first so meatheads with a chip on
their shoulder aren't given the license
to perform urban executions tough guys
have to do tough things right now it's
easy to spot the toughest police
officers they're the ones telling their
fellow cops you got to stop this [ __ ] a
crack has been made in the blue wall of
silence please let it break down even
further altogether or else we're going
to be in the streets again and again all
the time and in LA that doesn't work
because you know we're not really a
walking town
you